[Music]
hey guys just a quick one today I wanted
to share some training I did recently
using a chair and I'm not talking about
me boring obvious use of a chair as a
substitute for power let's dip bars or a
bench I'm talking about lifting the
chair my aim is to show that any tool or
even household item could potentially be
used as a functional training tool true
functional strength means being able to
adapt to the environment you find
yourself in which often means being
ready for unexpected and unpredictable
challenges using the chair here I'm
forced to handle the offset nature of
the weight the chair is top-heavy and
say by holding it from the bottom I
create a lever this allows the chair to
be swung just like an Indian club
develop core and shoulder strength and
mobility in other words the chair feels
much heavier and creates more muscle
growth when held further away from the
center of mass but the chair is even
longer than a club without being too
heavy more similar to mace training it's
also much wider at the top as compared
to a mace though and has multiple
convenient gripping points beholdin with
one or two hands in short actually works
as a very versatile tool for swinging
and bringing up over my head was more
though is that it's a significant
challenge trying to balance the chair
while gripping with one hand doing this
proved to be an incredible workout for
my forearms and grip that was fun and
looked pretty awesome this challenges
the slow twitch muscle fibers in the
forearm which must constantly adjust to
the changing angles of resistance it's
fantastic for developing proprioception
too and requires intense focus it
develops a precise kind of strength it
was say unique and challenging my hand
was shaking too an elector coffee mug
later on I've recently given this a name
strength finesse that's the ability to
recruit adjust the muscles needed to
subtly manipulate a heavy object this
could also refer to your own body weight
which I'll discuss soon so a chair can
be useful alternative to a club bell but
it also has uniquely beneficial
properties in its own right in other
words it can replace the club belt but
even if you have a club belt it can
still be worth exploring every object
can present a unique training challenge
that includes a plant pot a shopping
trolley railings garden table so get
creative
found this video useful interesting guys
thanks a ton for watching if you did
please leave a like and share it around
that helped me out immensely and if you
liked this alternative and theoretical
approach to training then you'll
probably enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training I'll
leave a link to that in the description
down below and there's a discount on at
the moment was for all in lock down
subscribe if you want to see more like
this and I'll see you soon thanks a ton
for watching and bye for now